Later nnova of the United States
of America. And to the Republic
for which it stands
one nation under god
indivisible.
Cristina.
That on.
Good afternoon thank you for
coming assembly member autumn
Burke and I represent the sixty
second assembly district which
includes Inglewood Hawthorne.
Gardena Lennix west Athens
marina Delray Venice.
El Segundo to name a few. I'd
think you for attending this
year th of this year's first
select committee hearing on
career technical education and
building a twenty first century
workforce.
I also and I think assembly
member Sabrina Cervantes for
hosting at this hearing and her
assembly district and Marco
community college for allowing
us to use the space to have this
important conversation.
I have been a champion for CT on
workforce development in the
California State Legislature
because I understand the role it
plays. For people getting living
wage jobs and for our economy to
grow it in California.
Workforce is important for every
community in California and
that's why we are here and thank
you for being here for to have
this conversation with us today.
The intent of this hearing is to
get a greater understanding of
the need for CT and workforce
development and to hear from the
people who are the boots on the
ground. And businesses who need
a skilled trained workforce.
This year I am proud to join the
author AB seventeen forty three
which is a bipartisan coalition
of members to ensure that we
continue funding. California's
career technical and education
incentive grant program at five
hundred million every year for
the next three years.
We understand that these
programs are more expensive so
we need to invest the adequate
funds of curriculum and tech
techniques keep up as economy is
changing so rapidly as you all
know.
We would be ill served if we
created economy of those who
have access to good paying jobs
and those who do not.
So we must ensure all
Californians have the
opportunity gain the skills
necessary to obtain a job that
provides a economic certainty
and security for their families
and we must support a strong and
growing middle class.
I wanna thank you in advance for
your support on these issues I I
see a lot of familiar faces here
and some new one so we're happy
to see you here. And now I will
turn it over to assembly member
Sabrina Cervantes for her
opening remarks.
Can everyone hear me excellent
so again good afternoon I am
assembly member Sabrina
Cervantes representing the
sixtieth assembly district. Aye
and that encompasses it while
the city of Norco the city of
east a bill corona group of
Valley. And portions of
riverside forty percent of the
city of riverside so thank you
for being with us today and
thank you for hosting the city
of Norco Norco committee college
for hosting us here. For today's
discussion but before we dive
into this I want to just think
my colleague chair of the select
committee assembly woman autumn
Burke for coming to the district
and. I seen the great
opportunities and we have here
right riverside county. I think
you for your willingness to come
here and share the your unique
relationship aye with what
you're doing and the LA county
area. And of course we're going
to hear a great testimony today
from many of our leaders within
the industry.
In any case with that some of
the challenges that we face I
want to give you a snapshot. Of
the Inland Empire in the
sixtieth assembly district
as a region in the Inland
Empire.
Our top industries I want to
share with you are advance
manufacturing global trade and
logistics and the health care
industry.
Within.
Evolving world of technology
information and communication
technology has been identified
as one of the key emerging
sectors of our time.
The unemployment rate here in
the sixtieth assembly district
is out three point seven
percent.
Slightly less than the overall
state average
so how do we continue to promote
these middle to high skilled
occupations and how do we
continue to educate the
necessary work force it takes.
To meet our industry needs.
So hopefully we can get a little
closer today and eh identifying
some of this those solutions
it's imperative that I recognize
the wonderful collaboration.
That we have between my office
and of course the president at
Norco college in this your and
your entire team. I president Dr
Reese.
In the back thank you so much
for your ongoing collaboration
and truly I do we taking that
extra step to.
Turn Norco college into Aurora
world renowned institution.
Yeah dot three so please feel
free to approach the podium to
provide some welcoming remarks
.
So thank you to both of you for
having us here today job I'd
like to make a few opening
remarks and then turn it over to
my colleagues here for us some
similar remarks.
I first of all I'd like to I
think.
Everybody for coming in welcome
to the beautiful Norco college
campus.
Were happy to hold these events
into please that.
You enjoy coming effort for
these hearings I think it's a
it's a win win for for both of
us.
You know one of the things we
talk a lot about in in higher ed
is this idea of building
pathways.
It's been a a very very strong
conversation going on in the
community colleges and in our
unified school districts.
And when we think about building
pathways or trying to do is
create a very clear.
Pathway of instruction for
students so there so they
understand exactly what courses
they need to take.
Courses they don't need to take.
And provide all kinds of support
around that pathway that helps
keep students
moving in a in a you know a
productive direction.
One of the big challenges in
creating a successful pathway is
getting to students to think
early on.
What the into that pathway looks
like
and that's where?
Career education comes in.
In my mind career education
Creek technical education is not
a program. It's a philosophical
approach to to higher ed every
single program that we offer on
campus leads to some kind of
career to leading in some
direction.
And it's.
It's important that we get
students to think about that I
know I know are not all students
are gonna know exactly what they
want to do.
You know I had.
All kinds of crazy ideas when I
was you know eighteen nineteen
twenty years old that type thing
but getting them to think along
the lines of where this.
This takes us is is really
critical to our students having.
A successful and
transformational experience
there a couple of things I'd
like to encourage you to think
about and I know there be more
details in the room.
As we go through the hearing.
Up first of all the idea of
guided pathways are I would like
to encourage you to continue
funding that program it's
something that the entire board
believes is having had a direct
impact.
It's something that's all three
colleges are working on it
something that corona Norco
unified Albert unified who rip
of al unified they're all we're
all trying to build. A these
pathways.
A second thing of like you know
a can continue supporting and
think about is to enrollment.
Are your colleagues in the
unified school district that
really thinking deliberately
about programs.
That lead students into careers.
The technical careers in in in a
professional careers.
And they once I and I and I want
to also build seamless pathways
that move from unified school
districts into the community
colleges and into jobs or into
the our community colleges and
Anna into the universities.
And this requires you know
unified school this of several
bureaucracy and we have our own
bureaucracy in these of these
have evolved over. Over decades
and they don't just you know
sync up release.
So we we have to be very
thoughtful about how we put
these together so it's a a a
seamless experience for students
in the requires. A a great deal
of time and energy and a little
bit of funding.
But I just to give you a quick
sense of how valuable these are
we are we have a program here at
JFK where we have students in
high school my transfer or they
take college classes through
dual enrollment. Bomb us last
year we invested about two
hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in taxpayer money to put
that connection together.
And we saved families in the
region about one point eight
million dollars and educational
cost because of the.
The seamless are because we're
able to offer this dual
enrollment program.
Other the third thing I'd like.
To mention is a pretty ships
this is a really impair
important program. Aye norcal
colleges on the front lines a of
a pretty ships United courage
you two are to continue
supporting this was very
important. That we get students
early and are to jobs so they're
able to to get a sense of how
practical they're studying yes
no it it adds meaning and value
to their to their education.
I'm gonna in my comments there
and I'd like to.
Turn it over to three my
colleagues here.
I'm not sure what order you
guys wanna go in but I'm
thinking we start with the
president the school board.
To receive a car is president
of our.
School border our board of
trustees we also have Mister
bell Hendrick he's our.
One of our. Board members also
and.
Doctor Irving Hendrix is also
here to represent RCC and the
and the college so alternate
overtop president.
In this you here today on behalf
of love my trustees Michael
trustees I can tell you that the
initiative around CT <c.green>
are</c>
probably one the for front ones
that we play talk about the
most.
In making sure that we're
identifying programs that bring
a living wage.
I am I have the great pleasure
of not only serving the colleges
a trustee on here in this region
but I also work in the area of
critical education. However
twenty any unified school
district in their I. M. the
college careers and economic
development director I bought
some of our team with us from
fontina we share a border with
riverside. And is a partner in
the region we are working on
initiatives together
collectively to identify how we
work together seamlessly between
all of our community colleges.
That represent the system and
how we were together is unified
school district and so it's a
pleasure to have you here were
happy to host you and we hope
that you'll come back and let
us.
Help you important would we
network without in the turn over
to my fellow trustee bill
Hedrick.
That some.
A it is a.
A pleasure to have you here
today.
I represent the communities of
corona Norco any stale.
But I want to applaud your
vision and the vision of our
president at Norco college.
This is clearly an initiative
that has the potential to change
lives.
And.
So with that said.
I know that of the work that
you do is so important the work
that doctor Reese and his team.
Does to.
Bring it to fruition on the
ground is so important.
We are so pleased.
To have this.
Hearing today and provide an
opportunity for the Inland
Empire to showcase the programs
that we have thank you.
On behalf of.
Chancellor world OB <c.green>
Saku</c>
is in Coronado today attending
to.
Pathways models our for career
technical education but also
transfer. Which is a big part
of.
What you're about to and at the
California assembly?
I'm happy to welcome you on
chancellor you socks of the
half.
.
Assembly member Burke thank you
so much for traveling to our
Norco today. A.
Assembly member Cervantes is say
a true friend of the riverside
community college district.
Of Norco college
and a close colleague to
assembly persons in this hour
area as we are the. At Norco.
We your in the gateway to the
riverside community college
district you travel east on the
sixty freeway. You go south on
the fifteen years ago. Aye east
and south on the ninety one.
Norco college is the gateway
and the gateway I think to
progress in career and technical
education we. We treasure our
Norco campus.
The campus it riverside of
course they're dating back to
nineteen sixteen is the oldest
in the most mature of the
colleges in the riverside
community college yet.
District at yes but.
President di.
Here was that not even born in
nineteen. Our.
A sixteen
so.
We care deeply about our.
Full employment but that's
already happening
so what the we're focusing now
on in career technical
education.
Be at it riverside City College.
Norco college where we are
today are Marino valley college
on sort of the eastern frontier
of the district. Is zeroing in
on living wage a jobs we're not
fighting unemployment and a long
their their play plenty of
minimum wage jobs.
But your the title of what you
are about.
Name way the.
Our the nexus between education
career readiness and work force
development. Is what we'll be
hearing about from our
colleagues behind us today and
now I'm looking forward to that
person way on behalf of chancery
sock.
And the district of riverside
community college thank you.
Well I wanted to say thank you
to our trustees and to doctor
recent doctor Hendrik for party
providing your remarks and look
for to. Hide diving into this
discussion and before we move on
I do want and I just
quickly high why we do have
elected officials from.
Almost each in my cities here as
well as the school board members
and so just thank you so much
for being here and being a
strong partner. High in this
endeavor.
But so thank you thank you all
as you as you get up from the
table and also I hope as I get
older they just keep calling me
more mature not old. I I'm going
to remember that for a long
time.
And everything that you all are
doing is exactly what what we
hope to promote and the seamless
pathways.
For young people moving forward
and for pressure programs are
tremendously important and
that's what we're here for today
so with that we have one last
housekeeping item. Should any
member from the audience wish to
sign up for public comment
there's a sign up sheet at the
back.
Where is it in the back it's
back in this corner over here
and so now we will move into our
first panel panelists please
come up and he can?
First up today we will have Jim
mayor president and CEO of
California forward.
Thank you for being here
gentlemen.
Good afternoon chairman Burke
and a member Cervantes thank you
for your leadership thank you
for the invitation to be here
today my name is Jim bear on the
presidency of California
forward.
California forward is the
managing partner of the
California economic summit which
is a seven year project public
private and Civic.
To develop.
And promote in advance a
roadmap to shared prosperity to
really. Get at the issue of
economic insecurity upward
mobility.
And develop the comprehensive
plan and the policies and
practices that would move the
needle on those issues.
Were of region's based effort
and an example that region's
based effort is a Pagani other
presidency of the Inland Empire
economic partnership here is a
been a strong and long
partnering co chair the summit's
during committee in a number
members and it's. Also this
partnership with.
All kinds of government
agencies in particular community
colleges Eli Oakley when he was.
Superintendent at Long Beach
City College was the co chair of
the summit in has been deeply
involved in our work.
That we all can I think
stipulate that while we have
cortical full economy a full
employment or near full
employment we've got a whole lot
of work to do.
Until we can address the poverty
issues in the income inequality
issues in California and one of
the roles of the summit is to
build understanding and
awareness of how big that
problem is what the dimensions
are what we can do about it and
so. Some of what we do is
publish things like the
California elevate California
index and it helps keep all of
us focused on just some of the
issues. So let me just cite a
couple of them of the items from
that index in nineteen seventy
five when I was a junior in high
school twenty five percent of
the young men ages twenty five
to thirty four. Got paid thirty
thousand dollars or less.
Today holding those dollars
constant forty one percent of
men in that age group make
thirty thousand dollars or less
and seventy five dollars. That's
a huge erosion of our middle
class.
Five million Californians have
minimum wage workers according
to the LA Joh and according to
the LA a thirty two percent of
those employers are the only.
Wage earner in their family they
may be the only person in their
family but and there that
they're the only wage earner.
And there seven hundred
disconnected youth and the state
of California sixteen to twenty
four who are at school. Or
employ.
I'm so we're not at full
employment and we've got a big
way to go if what we want to do
is address these.
One of the things the summit is
doing in this next year is
trying to promote the idea of
putting in state law.
Metrics and targets for
addressing these issues of
income inequality in upper
mobility.
We've seen the power of the
efforts to curb greenhouse gases
in California where we set a
goal we set a target we unleash
the power of the public and
private sector to. To move
toward that end and if we're
serious and we are
about addressing these issues we
should do the same for.
For unemployment and we should
do the same for income
inequality would do should do
the same for reducing poverty
and. Member Burke we look
forward to working with you on
the AB fifteen twenty task force
denigrate some of those metrics
and the good work that's already
under way to develop similar
metrics for. Children and family
and poverty.
And now that it's important for
us to recognize even as we
continue to focus on this
imperative of workforce
development that it's it's part
of a system it is only one part
the system that's gonna be
necessary for those California's
to reach those goals.
And if you look at the roadmap
for sure prosperity there's a
lot and there are and what we
need to do in order to build
houses a to build community
development and in particular
and housing.
It should be noted that that the
housing crisis is growing much
faster than wages.
And Wilk in will continue to a
road.
The middle class economic
security if if we don't do
something about housing two
years ago mackenzie on behalf of
California for the summit did a
study that showed that
California's pay at least at
least their low estimate fifty
billion dollars a year more for
housing than they should. And
those are by low income families
and that money should be spent
on education it should be spent
on their own retirement it
should be spent on other.
Necessities so you we have to
remember the relationship
between what you're working on
today and all the other things
that you work so hard on
Sacramento when we do in the
rear.
And there's also another thing
we need to focus on and that is
that.
By an estimate done for the
summit by Stanford University
were short nine hundred thousand
median wage jobs if the metric
was one median wage job for
every household. So we actually
need to be worried about it
thinking about what the business
climate is and what the
strategies are for growing the
right kinds of jobs in our
regions throughout the state.
Now finally the third part is
this human development and
workforce development has been a
key element from the summit
since day one.
That our partners in the summit
Bammer have been very involved
in the development of the strong
workforce program where involved
in the task force we did
regional meetings. To help bring
invoices from six from students
from disadvantaged communities
and from the employment
community so that the
recommendations that move
forward to the governor in the
legislature incorporated some of
those voices we've been involved
in directly. Implementing the
strong workforce program not
because it's an answer but
because it's an example
of how we can do it needs to get
done to make best use of
available resources.
To get students from where they
are to employment and what
they've trained for on an upper
mobility track.
From the work over the last few
years I think there's for
lessons that we can draw that
are part of our prescription
going forward for all of our
human development and workforce
development work.
The first is we we absolutely
need to continue to make
progress in this alignment.
Between where students are and
what skills they have and and
and not just.
Classes but programs and
curriculum that will prepare
them.
For industry valued credentials
and other industry valued
milestones that lead to
employment.
And in that there's still work
to be done there and some of the
topic in testimony today here is
about how to get that align.
The second is we just need to be
ruthless about efficiency and
this isn't from a business
standpoint of squeezing out
every time. The reality is the
faster students can move from
where they are to that living
wage job. We're gonna save a lot
of money and most of that money
is theirs
most of that money is money that
that they lose because they are
not employed in those jobs
whether spending too long
getting through that pipeline.
And so we have to continue to
find ways about.
How to accelerate that not so
that it is superficial so it's
meaningful so get some where
they have to be but we have to
recognize that the cost of that
inefficiency is mostly born by
the young people in a better
job?
A third is we need to redefine
access we are proud and we
should be proud in the state of
California for defining open
access particularly community
colleges. Around fees and and
the ability to get and the
ability to keep taking classes
are to start and stop I'm a
product of that system I have in
a from a community college.
But it's about much more than
that because access now is not
just about getting in the door
not being fees it's about
offering what's needed when it's
needed and where it's needed.
And we need to embrace a
variety of ways to do that
including technologies that are
not only going to allow us to.
Do things like on offer online
classes but offer a but to
infuse faster competency based
classes and a start and and and
then the link up especially with
employers and this is another
part of your. Somatic element
today so.
It's really clear not only
today but especially going
forward.
That we're gonna have to find a
way to double down and build
even deeper.
Employer educational
partnerships going forward
McKenzie did another study last
year not for the summit that
just as useful that says and by
twenty thirty fifteen percent of
the jobs will be replaced or
obsolete because of machine
learning or automation
artificial intelligence fifteen
percent of the jobs.
So we're faced with this dilemma
that right now we've got a whole
lot of people that need the
skills in order to get better
jobs.
And at the same time were
worried about what those jobs
but with which jobs are gonna
disappear and what we need to do
to prepare those people for it.
We don't know the answers to all
of those questions but we do
know we can build an
infrastructure. That allows for
greater access greater
efficiency greater adaptability
and working with partnerships
with employers to understand
where those dislocation changes
are gonna happen before the pink
slips come out and people can
get para to take those jobs.
One final word.
And this comes back to another
thread this come through the
summit from mark Bassano the
former executive officer of the
southern California association
a governor of. Governments now
USCS a longtime member the
summit network recently wrote a
book and much after it says no
once disposable.
Because of the demographic
trends become because all of us
baby boomers are going to retire
and in the work force behind us
isn't as large. And we actually
gonna need everybody engaged and
in our economy if we want our
economy to grow and we want to
meet the basic workforce needs
it's not just about skills it's
about the skills for everybody
who's in that workforce. As I
mentioned we've got seven
hundred thousand disconnected
you we've also got five hundred
thousand mostly men but men and
women who are in our criminal
justice system in prison in jail
on probation or parole. There
are hundreds of thousands of
others that are formally
incarcerated not on the systems
but still face barriers to
employment. Those are examples
about how we have to find
everybody in our community and
create a pathway the president
re said to get them into full
employment that's our challenge
I think we're up to it thank you
for the opportunity to give you
some reflections.
Thank you Jim next step is
Lauren que president of
California foundation for
commerce and education.
But.
Thank you assembly member.
Cervantes sins of.
Chairman of Burke
a very pleased to be here Marin
que was California foundation
for commerce and education were
the.
Nonprofit think tank affiliated
with California chamber of
commerce.
We do research and policy
studies we also.
Are the lead on some.
Local employer partnerships on
work based learning which I'll
talk about the few minutes. Very
pleased to have been invited to.
Address you today and have the.
.
Excuse in the pleasure to come
don't Norco in the.
.
Find community culture.
Now.
Given your position on this
committee your.
Probably as familiar more
familiar than I am of the work
force challenges but I want to.
Put it in the context of an. Of
an employer.
A and what what employers are
are facing and all of a quote
from a.
Robert Klein hands of beacon
economics in he said very well
he said with the stated full
employment.
Our and your your you mention
your district being a three
point seven percent. Of
unemployment.
A job growth in general economic
gains will largely be
constrained by the availability
of of workers
is is good for workers who might
achieve.
Pay increases in the coming
months supporters but poses a
challenge for firms for
businesses that want to grow but
cannot.
Because they're unable to hire
the necessary workers.
Data at the national level
indicates the job openings in
general have reached historic
highs is holds true for most
industries whether they're high
school.
A low skilled.
Manufacturing of those services.
Of. Its it so prevalent
throughout the condom history
hearing California nationally
fifty percent of open available
positions in this country. Go
unfilled.
Because candidates are available
at the same time forty percent
of businesses can't take on more
work because they can't fill the
jobs that they need to do the
work.
So we've got a real mismatch.
Between our talent needs in the
pipeline of new and potential
workers in this this gets into
what Jim was talking about with
the retirement.
Of the baby boom generation of.
Our population cohorts coming in
behind them were.
You know we don't have the
robust immigration we've had in
the in the past is a whole lot
of things that enter into this
but.
You still result with the same
problem.
Of low unemployment but.
The.
Less of an opportunity for
businesses and the economy to
grow so we've out what the six
seventh eighth largest economy
in the world.
But we need to have a produce
another.
Of what one point one million
jobs of of a.
College degrees
of three twenty thirty in order
to keep that economy.
Does that economy going out and
the reality is even.
For this for for the students
it is Saddam.
How is difficult and that's real
also ran into a mismatch only
forty percent of the state's?
Two point two million young
adults that so.
Through a about age thirty.
Holden associates degree or
higher in many lack the skills
for for success it's even worse
for underrepresented students
less than ten percent.
Of low income adults.
Or the post secondary degree.
And you've got similar gaps
entertainment for.
Of students of color in the
state where fifty five percent.
A public school students are
from low income families sixty
percent.
Students of color.
The educational and career
outcomes
are inextricably linked to the
economy and vice versa were all
in this together.
So.
Would we want to do about.
There's lots of strategies in
her about a lot of today the one
that I want to.
Plug in particular.
As called link learning and you
may you may have you may have
heard of this I know that.
Some schools in your districts
of.
Bob are linked learning schools
are about a hundred districts
statewide the do it but I want
to. Just go into a little bit
and tell you why we like.
Ugh that we think that it has
the best prospect for providing
a long term pipeline of well
qualified students will meet the
needs of. That the needs of
employers and of the economy.
And enabling these.
High school graduates college
grads to stay in Californian
jobs.
Pay well and it of god the
prospect for upward mobility.
Basic philosophy behind link
learning.
Is the idea the students work
harder and dream Baker.
If there education is relevant
to them.
The approach integrates rigorous
academics the beach meet college
ready standards.
Sequenced high quality career
technical education work based
learning.
And the supporting environment
help students stay on track so.
Four components rigorous
academics.
Career technical education work
based learning comprehensive
support services so why focus on
both.
Career in college we hear a lot
about well. You know as a but
just
there's a whole bunch of jobs a
don't need a four year college
education a. Whole bunch of.
Students who don't go to college
why don't why should we focus
on.
Being college ready well.
Couple reasons one is the
probability of making a living
wage.
In our economy special in
California.
Without some form of post
secondary education is low and
it's only gonna diminish.
Increasingly career success
depends on some kind of a post
secondary degree your credential
whether it's a certificate and
apprenticeship.
On associates degree though
those are all things that are
provide right here at at at
Norco. Or.
About shoes degree or or or
something higher.
Secondly.
Without an explicit goal.
For preparing high school
students for a full range
post graduation opportunities.
You risk.
Reverting to tracking students.
Tracking students entered into
choices that an adult thinks.
Is right for that student and
an adult may decide whether a
student is ready for college and
we just want to go back there
thing that's.
That's a.
That's a placer we we we don't
want to return to.
So in addition a rigorous
academics each pathway centers
on increase student proficiency
in areas such as.
Critical thinking problem
solving.
Information literacy
collaboration these of the soft
skills you hear about the boy
would be to say they are really
really important.
Once you get into the once again
of the work place.
Not speaking of workplace accord
part of.
The learning experience and
Winkler inning is work based
learning.
This is where.
Students can apply their
classroom learning.
In a professional setting and
gain the real world experience
in the process they learn what
it takes to being in the
professional world.
.
And they learn how to interact
with people.
On the job the other not
necessarily working these can be
job shadowing mentor ships.
.
Speakers.
Arm or our actual actual
internships.
Are but it's all part of a of a
vote.
Link learning experience the
become more engaged excited
about their education.
And they can.
Really answer and an intuitive
level.
Why do I need to learn what it
is I'm learning in the
classroom?
So what's our role in this.
A. There's.
Unfortunately.
.
In under engagement by
California employers in
providing workplace experiences
for youth despite the really
strong business case for.
Of for making this happen it's a
lot easier.
To grow work.
That is becoming familiar with
you rather than going out trying
to recruit it specially across
state lines.
US so we are of working with
link learning alliance.
With the U. S. chamber of
commerce.
And other entities to develop
networks in California of local
chambers of the working with
their members.
To.
Build different kinds of work
based learning models at their
employers are. Can use of we've
been doing this for the last
several years. This year on
please to say that were. Just
starting up a new network with a
six local chambers of commerce
that are involved in this.
I including the riverside.
Chamber of commerce in the Los
Angeles.
Chamber of commerce of. Of.
Two two of the six
and will be you are working to
develop different models for
work basin.
Learning for engagement between
employers and school districts
to expose their their students
to this and.
Of all be pleased to report.
To you later on how that works
out and I would invite you to
visit your school districts that
are have linked learning.
Programs and with the chambers
that are involved in that thank
you.
And now up is my good friend Jan
vocal executive director and CEO
of South Bay workforce
investment board.
Now yes.
Thank you and thank you for your
leadership and inviting me to
this a hearing today and and
assembly member Cervantes also.
Some of what I was gonna say was
already said by.
The gentleman that to my right
side I want to repeat that.
So I'm just gonna go quickly
here.
This out the boards.
The work force boards are the
entity is the is the entity that
can connect.
Chambers and the businesses to
the education partners that's
what we do that's what we're
here for. If we wanna get the
most out of those courses that
are being taught to as
particularly the underserved
population.
And the businesses that know
what they need.
It's the boards that can help
them directly it could be the
link and we are the glue in our
community to be able to do that.
South Bay private SLP workforce
investment board serves eleven
cities and South Bay area many
of those cities are assembly
members Burke. And.
Of what we do are basically get
people jobs and help business
that's it that's all we want to
do how do we do that well a lot
of the work force development
education. That we do happen to
do a host industry sector
meetings develop pre
apprenticeship programs now
apprenticeship programs provide
the paid internships in the paid
work experience to those
individuals we also have a
directory of schools in our
area.
That directly to schools list.
Education entities are going to
live to it lead to a job
it doesn't lead to a job they're
not going to be in our
directory.
Almost all the boards in the LA
basin and an Orange County use
our directory wide of the user
directory because if you stay on
our directory they know that the
results are going to be a job if
it's not a job. Those schools
come offered them off the
directory
and in our area sixteen
community colleges are listed.
On our directory and and
hundreds of our courses are
listed so the community colleges
are doing quite well. And doing
better and better.
With the partnerships in being
able to lead to jobs.
Some of the areas where we
partner with community colleges
and educational institutions we
have a work study program. The
work study program.
Is funded partly by LA county
department of public social
service.
A community colleges a dozen
community colleges in the LA
county area. Are individuals
that are on ten if they're going
to community colleges
a community colleges place them
on work sites the begin work
experience
we pay those students
well right actually we pay fifty
percent.
And the community colleges pay
fifty percent
the great partnership
partnership between education.
And department of the social
service and it works.
One of the programs we have you
gonna be you're going to be
looking at.
Various.
.
Job readiness programs in a
little while but we have a job
readiness program called
blueprint for workplace success.
Individuals that go through that
curriculum by thirty our
curriculum sometimes twenty.
They end up with a hot much
higher probability getting
employed we teach them not only
how to get a job how to keep a
job.
Books are available it's also
taught online the colleges that
use it love it.
Career pathways career pathways
you heard a lot about repair
fleas.
We partner with the K. twelve
schools we partner with the
community colleges.
We partner with.
Various organizations and
provide workplace activities
and.
Provide guest speakers job
shadowing pre apprenticeship
deal with lots of different
school districts
and tell consortium is one of
the programs. That were a
partner and.
There are five colleges that
partner with us six
intermediaries for of those
intermediaries our work for
sports.
Fourteen school districts
it's for engineering and
manufacturing that's what the
school districts are centering
on and that's what we're doing
linking them in link learning
linking them to opportunity so
that they can succeed.
One program which is a great
example of a partnership.
Would be our slingshot nursing
program we brought all of our
hospitals into one room and we
said what do you need what can
we do to help you. They said we
need case coordinators case
managers is various names for it
they said that's what's going to
be the demand in the next five
years.
So that's what we did we brought
the community colleges and we
said we need a curriculum
curriculums been developed. But
a million dollars the state
provided order provide this and
starting this month.
The first group of case
coordinators are gonna be
trained through our.
Community colleges primarily and
we're going to have.
Incumbent workers getting
retrained and upgraded to.
Supplement their nursing skills
would case coordination
individuals coming out of
college getting this starting
this month we're really proud of
that initiative took about three
years to get going wouldn't of
happened without the businesses
in the room. Telling us what
they need.
We have another program locally
called Errol flex Affleck's
program couldn't be more proud
of this program.
It is it started out as a pre
apprenticeship era era flicks
program for engineering
students.
And putting them in.
Various aerospace companies
learning.
How to be an engineer what they
want to do go to college keep a
end clued in their education so
that they can? Of become
successful last week we were
notified by the federal
department of labor.
That we were granted.
Status as the first
apprenticeship program
for and aerospace engineers in
the country
so that's an out growth of this
pre apprenticeship program.
Real.
Real happy about that so we're
gonna be taking high school
kids.
Community college individuals
college individuals incumbent
workers and making sure that
they succeeded increase their
potential.
That's what boards.
Do many of them doing should do
is be the glue we don't teach
the engineering the schools
teach the engineering but we
made it happen. And we're real
proud of that.
Era flicks program it's it's
it's overlaying the traditional
education systems.
Putting on top of that an
apprenticeship programs so we
designed this apprenticeship
program so that the employers
tell us. What the students need
to be successful
and then we bring in the proper
educational components to make
sure that success now we're
designing other apprenticeship
programs?
Using the template of the
aerospace engineering program
it's terrific some of the other
innovative programs that were
doing that are connected to
education. Were about to start
the uniquely able project in
which were taking high
performing.
Autistic individuals and
training them to be CNC machine
es
we have the employers lined up
we have the community college
lineup is going to do the
training and they're going to be
placed. In businesses because of
this unique partnership.
With they with some of our
community colleges were also
taking graduates who have
disabilities.
And we're gonna be placing them
in various businesses that are
already lined up we couldn't of
done it without this community
colleges but they couldn't of
done it without us.
Because the community colleges
they don't have to keep
developing different.
Employer partnerships.
That's what we do they should
use us to be able to do that and
leverage our funds.
And
funds we needs of huts
we had about fifty percent cut
in funds the last ten years.
For what we do and it for WYO a
which is our core funding.
We we were able to spend seventy
percent of those funds on in
school youth in the pass for a
youth program. Now we can only
spend twenty five percent on in
school youth.
Well we love and school you've
we're not gonna not serve in
school use but obviously we need
money we need partnerships were
working with community colleges.
They're.
Where we're grateful that some
of them are providing strong
workforce money to us to be able
to do that? But unless we're
able to partner on those they
could get some funds for that.
We can't do what we do best.
Lots of different programs the
promise program promise programs
throughout California now we've
been doing it for years.
Where the with the kids are
getting paid a tuition and books
for the first year we're taking
them to community colleges and
four year colleges putting them
up in dorms? Little kids faith
great kids
we put him up the doors of the
Vic the experience of what
college is like.
That's a partnership we put all
the chambers of commerce
together one day.
With all of our cities and
economic development directors
they've never even met before
and we said what do you need
what do you want us to do. They
gave us a list we did it.
Exceeding.
Okay I'm gonna hurry up here
when I let when a to two
meetings that had recently I
left the meeting this morning
when I came over here. In the
room was the department of
rehabilitation in our area.
A parole department.
And the work for sport.
We're gonna take and it's
happening now were taken and
parolees
who need a job desperately.
Structured work is is abundant.
They're eligible to work those
construction jobs
seventy or eighty percent are
eligible for rehabilitation.
So we want to get money from
department a rehabilitation
which they have.
And put them in this
construction jobs.
That's starting to work it's
going to work it's going to be a
great partnership last week we
had a youth council meeting we
meet every quarter our board.
I looked around the room we had
seven.
Superintendents from school
districts
a community college president.
A representative from a four
year college and a region
occupation superintendent in the
same room.
And one of the superintendents
Tami and announced to the to the
group I've been doing this for
three years.
This is the meeting that I get
the most out of.
One of our superintendents as a
trustee in Inglewood was our
first meeting.
She said
she was overwhelmed
getting those people together
that's what boards do they're
the glue.
We need to be used to be able to
accomplish what you need to
accomplish and we love our.
Business partners and our
education partners thank you.
Thank you now our final panelist
Jim Miller Dada chair riverside
county workforce investment
board.
Thank you assembly member.
A Burke assembly member.
.
A Cervantes
for coming out.
Turn it on
sorry.
Thank you for.
Allowing me to speak aye aye I
would. Agree with Jan.
And I should say that I've known
John for twenty five years
he's a close friend and he's
been one of my mentors. I've
learned a lot from him so if I
say anything you don't like.
We're going to blame blame
Janet.
So you might get of you might
get a slightly different
perspective from me.
Because.
I I think I'm a little bit
different than all the speakers
you heard from because.
I'm a business leader and this
is a volunteer job for me but I
love doing this stuff.
So I've been a member. And in
the workforce system I been
doing this for. Almost twenty
five years.
I'm the chair of this County
Board.
I have.
Been on the California workforce
board for fourteen years
so work very closely with David
Lanier Mike Rossi.
And I'm a past chair of the
California workforce board.
And also said on the and by the
way I'm on the executive
committee there and I also sit
on the national workforce board
I work with the federal
department of labor.
And I frequently testified
before congressional committees
in Washington DC so I'm gonna
just give you a. Slightly
different perspective from an
employer. From a business side.
And and Jan is right aye I speak
all over the country and people
ask me all the time will how
many jobs did you workforce
board create. The workforce for
does not create jobs the
workforce would break basically
is like the quarterback in any
community and as you know
California has forty seven work
for sports.
And whenever I'm in Washington I
was remind legislators that even
though we're one of fifty states
one out of every eight people in
the country.
Lives in California.
Somebody wants to listen
everybody's interested.
But we connect the people we
have.
Business leaders labor education
nonprofits government. And we
train workers we help dislocated
workers and all the forty seven
work for sports actually all
five hundred fifty of the work
force boards that are funded by
Congress. Also run youth
opportunity centers.
And and in the Inland Empire.
We have a total of eleven Butte
centers with almost two thousand
disconnected youth between the
ages of sixteen and twenty four.
That all success stories once
they've gotten enrolled in our
system.
So you've heard a lot of numbers
and most of the stuff that I
would like to talk about already
been said so but. Maybe I can
just give you a slightly
different spin.
The.
College graduates are amazing
right for your university the
graduate.
They can't find a job.
We have employers call are
America's job centers everyday.
Then ask for
a certain.
Type criteria of workforce.
We don't have those so.
When I talk about it it sounds a
little weird you know you us
assembly member Cervantes
mentioned our unemployment is
down to three point seven which
is.
Almost considered full
employment full employment.
But yet there's so many jobs
looking for people.
We can't provide them and
everybody talks about there's a
shortage of high skilled workers
that the shortage of high
skilled workers there is. But
for us in the Inland Empire
there is a shortage of middle
skilled workers you know if
they're the forgotten middle
because we don't really have a
lot of high skilled companies
that are looking for.
Big time the majority of the
folks.
The in California even that need
to find jobs a middle skilled
workers
we've just got to find a better
way.
To do that now of this gentleman
mentioned.
The four year universities and I
hope there's nobody here
representing a four year
university because I don't
offend anybody.
I have.
To millennials at home and they
did both both go to four year
universities but everybody
doesn't need to go to four year
university so many other.
Students that come out of four
year universities have these
huge debts and then they can't
find a job. So I wanna
references survey nine years ago
when we had the mortgage
meltdown the national workforce
board did a survey a national
survey around the country.
And they ask employers if you
have a college graduate looking
for a job posting you have and
you have a sixty five year old
older worker because that was
the time when everybody's for
one case were decimated and a
lot of older workers.
Wanted to stay.
So we asked them who would you
hire and seventy five percent of
them said of course we would
hire the college graduate
because there are you know more
passion that they have.
They're more they know more
stuff.
Last year we did the same survey
at seventy five percent of them
said well heart of the older
workers.
Because the younger people
nowadays.
And I think part of this is
because we decimated the ROP
programs from the schools.
When I was going to high school
eighty three percent of the
students in high school had some
connection to business.
Now we did the state board did
some numbers two years ago and
less than ten percent of the
students in high schools of any
connection to business.
So when they graduate and when
they go for a job interview.
They're never St don't know what
to do so we gotta figure out a
way to connect.
Schools and businesses together
when I talk about.
I see business that doesn't
necessarily mean private sector
employment even though. I'm an
officer riverside counties would
largest community bank but I'm
not just talking about private
sector.
Government jobs.
Healthcare jobs nonprofit jobs
any employer.
There's a disconnect.
So.
When sometimes when I speak in
front of young people I remind
them that employment is by
invitation only.
Because they will tell me I have
a degree Y. want to hire me
well.
You know it there's gotta be a
match.
So you have probably heard of
the sling shot program that
we're doing through the state
board.
And we.
.
That split the country of the
state up into fourteen regions
in the Inland Empire is one
region so riverside county
workforce development board and
the symbol of the not county
border working as one.
And what we're doing there is
basically were convening. And
we've identified to hide them
growth sectors here healthcare
and manufacturing and what we've
done is we've brought.
A top level folks from those two
industries together and have
them tell us what do you need
what workers do you need and
then be done that the.
Educational institutions and
said.
Okay.
Britain prepare curriculum to
match this and then if they come
out and they go through that
certification.
They're guaranteed a job so
everybody doesn't need to go to
four year university folks can
get out of high school go to an
apprenticeship training program
through that. Trades
and they can start making twenty
five dollars an hour at age
twenty twenty one twenty two
they can go into aerospace that
can become.
Plumbers or electricians or
auto mechanics and they can have
family supporting jobs community
colleges will play a big role
associates degrees yes.
But four year universities are
great for some people. We just
have to not have this bias.
For young people saying all
you're a failure because you
don't go to four year university
I'm going to stop there because
I know of was short on time
thank you. For listening.
I think you are right you know I
actually have a quick question
since you just since you were
when a little shorter thing your
time. How as an employer did
used get started in working with
the workforce investment board
what was what was that kind of
catalyst for that?
As an employer world was looking
for workers and I was involved
in the chamber of commerce.
And I had heard that.
There are a this is the nation's
public workforce system
so I called my county
supervisor.
And had them appoint me.
And my wife is still cursing
that county supervisor. Thought
that.
We'll tell her we we appreciate
it.
A pleasure.
So I just hearing our panelist
in this dire.
Discussion it was quite exciting
for me to hear about. The new
innovative CT models and
pathways
I that. Is happening now in the
LA county area czar it unites
only want to see that.
Here riverside county that's
great you know Jim million
mentioned some.
Things that I know riverside
county is working on. How can we
further ensure that we how about
middle skilled workforce to hear
what what is it that you need
from the state legislature?
You can share your thoughts
I think. One of the encouraging
things this morning with the
budget the new federal budget
because of all this money comes.
From the vets and the workforce
dollars a different grants.
Through the labor agency on the
various agencies so.
The two year budget actually has
put more money and then what the
president wanted so now we're
going to go over the next three
months going to continue to
advocate the appropriations
committees to make sure.
But I I just came back from
Washington DC I was there the
last three days and.
Ninety percent of the members of
Congress we talk to both sides
of the aisle programs in fact
the president
even keeps pushing
apprenticeship programs. So I
think that the workforce
innovation opportunities act
funding is going to continue and
there will be more grants
competitive grants and
California always does well with
those so.
The state board of the labor
agency will continue to do that
I guess one of the challenges we
have assembly rooms Cervantes
and you can help us.
And and not to take anything
away from you but we have to
always compete with the coastal
counties.
So we'll have to just have.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Can I also chime in on that.
The Senate but they assembly
bill I think assembly bill one
one one one.
That I know you support.
A assembly member Burke and this
is one that will provide us
needed resources to be able to
continue doing what we're able
to do. And another thing that
can be done by the assembly and
the Senate is this.
Always look to us to provide us
more flexibility.
Because.
There are so many restrictions
on what we can and cannot do
most of what we do is is has
nothing to do with the act
itself that we're doing. Is to
help the people that we need we
don't get paid to work with the
community college is a special
fine. But we do because we know
we have to so flexibility.
To allow us to be able to
deliver the best services
possible to our clients.
You can push for more.
Career pathways.
Programs and for more a industry
community college partnerships
that'll make a big difference
that's what's going to happen.
You know we're and we're working
on the five hundred million but.
I know it's it's never enough.
.
I have one other question about
soft skills.
I I know you mentioned that that
was kind of one of the things
you felt link learning was was
providing and it's one of the
things we hear rate your lead
where are. You.
That are are falling behind and
I'm just curious what you see is
the best way to kind of promote
those soft skills to create it's
one thing for kids to go to
school told. To learn the to get
there are basic education but it
this day and age soft skills are
so important kids text messaging
in interviews things like that.
Who curious what your thoughts
are?
Yeah I think you hit on at the
it's.
It's on the job of a high school
teacher to teacher of.
Of a young person.
.
Job readiness skills.
Of.
You know.
Maybe somebody could argue it
should be but it isn't tonight
which and expected to be. A.
Of that should be.
Developed.
Really with the experience at at
at a work site because there's
nothing that the substance for
that.
In the way you do that.
Is by having these of work based
learning opportunities in the
way you get these work based
learning opportunities is
through.
Some form of its
it's either Linklater knitting
its arm.
Of.
Any other programs through the a
incentive grants maybe through
the governor's. Proposal it it
really doesn't it really doesn't
matter how it's done as long as
there is a.
Way for the.
.
For the high schools and to it
and to a certain extent the
community colleges
to develop these relationships
with employers.
And that's where what what were
you come in on this.
Is.
.
Our is providing that. Increment
of funding because this is.
More expensive is not part of
the core.
Mission of of of a high school
it's of the need that
incremental funding to develop
these.
These these partnerships and of
a that's where the students were
and I like to put in one other.
One other plug.
On the.
That of president Reese
mentioned a few minutes ago on
tool enrollment I think that's a
that's a.
Which we found that to be a
very successful.
A way to advance.
.
Of the students into thinking
about the workplace eight.
In a many students of there's
really great examples in the
Central Valley for example.
Who graduate from high school?
Almost have an a a degree and
they are.
Ready to be certified and have
of a post high school graduate
degree where they can get into
the workplace or get and it.
Get into college.
Into a four year institution or
quickly so it might wanna put in
a plug for that as well.
Thanks I like to think the first
panel for their comments and we
will move to our second panel
and ask those who are in the
same bill to come up
.
One of the.
Well.
We had manager.
And before we get started on our
next panel I do wanna invite
everyone in attendance should
join us for a reception shortly
after this will have a
networking reception just down
the hallway.
So first up our panelist is
Dennis Sonny Inland Empire
region adviser California
manufacturing technology
consulting.
Hello good afternoon. A sunny
Dennis sunny thank you for
inviting me to be here.
Thank you all for your
participation and interest. In
this.
So I'm with that the National
Institute of standards and
technology through the
department of commerce and
there's a center in every single
state I've worked with this
center for twelve years now. I
am boots on the ground diced
I've stepped and over seven
hundred and fifty manufactures.
I'm a gadget guy. Automation
man bye by trade and I guess.
My my career started out in the
marine corps after the marine
corps I bought my home I was
twenty two years old I Bob my
home and group of Valley and I'm
still there today.
So thank you.
These a lot of this we've heard
this this afternoon about.
.
The the fourth industrial robot
revolution is here and it is
growing.
I had the pleasure of being a
part of the and the and am show
this week.
And Anaheim there was nineteen
thousand manufacturers that were
at the show and I played ping
pong with the robots and saw all
kinds of really cool
technologies that's out there.
And I'm thankful that Alexa
reminded me to get my stuff
together to come here today and.
You know and and my uber is and
and and ways helped me navigate
my way to this facility. But the
strength of our economy it's it
drives the technology
advancements.
There's over six hundred
thousand open manufacturing
positions I today I met with the
company last week they had
thirty eight jobs that were
open.
Thirty eight they're trying to
fail
I'm seen twelve manufacturers
every single month I have a
team.
And.
There's tube like they they
said earlier there's two point
seven million baby boomers that
are gonna be retiring over the
next decade.
An estimated by two thousand
twenty five two million jobs and
advanced manufacturing or will
go on failed.
Another important fact is
there's it takes about ninety
days for manufacture to recruit
a highly skilled worker today.
And that current workforces
deficient requiring future and
skills training.
I am and where are we deficient
of course it's the technology
computer skills the problem
solving skills the basic
technical training and math
skills.
I like this that this
display I put up here it's it's
a robot on display but it's that
it's a person who is.
Generating and telling the robot
what to do but not only that.
He's doing some innovation
thinking thinking about that
process in his supply chain.
So maintaining the industry
growth. It will allow us in this
region to position this region
has a major player and advanced
logistics cement manufacturing
it gives us the competitive
edge.
So what I'm after really is the
manufacturing industry chatter
aye I want people talking about.
I want them to consider. A
career path in manufacturing
there's there's so many really
cool technologies that are used
out there today.
They need to percent.
So the impact of what this is
doing to the manufacturing work
force gap.
I eighty two percent. It it's
gonna affect customer demand
seventy eight percent it's going
to in fact their productivity of
manufacturing.
Our customer service.
A being able to make goods to
that pace that needs to be said
about the need be made from.
The impact and the ability to
innovate to develop.
So what we need we need right
people we need right skills
right time a right plan and
write because.
I love this say they shot here
this was from the last year I
took a group of.
Students robotic students and
gamers students.
Through a company and this is
colony high school. Of it we did
some really they're holding up a
little plate here what I like to
about this is I'm taking the
children into a manufacturing.
It environment so they can see
smell here and and see this
first hand and and and that's
where I I I love the excitement.
Into to work with these these
children.
So one of the work force needs
there's a list up here of what's
needed here and when I looked at
this less putting together this
presentation today was like well
there's going to be people in
the room that. You know there's
there's some of these things we
cannot a fact so I removed those
things here and so under the
skilled production workers. What
we really need to do is it is it
create an attractive
attractiveness of this industry?
And the and the access to talent
goes on to the other side the
engineering research and
scientists but it was
interesting to look at this data
as I put this all together for
you today.
So what a CMT see doing a
specifically in the Inland
Empire I've been in the Inland
Empire a very passionate about
manufactures in the Inland
Empire.
.
Assembly woman thank you for
shadowing me out and the
manufacturing plants it's an
honor to have you inside those
plants seen for yourself. Of
what they're making.
I my mother moved into my guest
house about two years ago and as
I drive around the Inland Empire
I'm pointing out there making
skateboards they're they're
doing baseball bats they're
they're making bottles there.
It's it's a crazy little her way
to drive with me but there's so
many cool things that are
happening in this region so what
are we doing. I've organized.
In this region a CEO group and
for four years now the CEO grope
their all.
Manufactures we come together
once a month and through this
group I've been taking this
group into schools to speak and
talk about to the youth about
how they started in maybe in
their garage.
And.
It gets that the students very
excited about this.
.
I am part of the corona
manufactures council I'm part of
the fines Hannah manufactures
counsel I work very closely work
with the workforce development
board. And and we have the peer
counsel.
At through CMT see.
Of we provide recruitment
services for management in the
higher technology positions at
the manufacturing level.
And another thing that I am very
passionate about his national
manufacturing day have. Have
from a sigh of hands who is
aware of national manufacturing
day is the very first Friday. Of
October I speak throughout the
Inland Empire about this day and
what I love about this day is
it's a day were manufactures can
open up their doors. And allow
the community their suppliers
their employees families to come
into that cell manufacturing
plant and see what's being made
in this region.
.
So we do that we are part of the
whole make and you make it in
America program the California
make program. And of course the
MTC we do have a TP funding for
incumbent new hire training. And
that also supports a career
ladders.
As an entry as that.
.
I man who focuses on the
manufacturers in this region I
am partnered with the community
college.
I I love working with the Norco
campus here they have five
different apprenticeship
programs that I am I I steer out
been and and use through my
manufactures.
I use the Norco branch almost
like my apple one aye aye. They
have.
Ways of helping my manufactures
fill these positions.
As I put this the slide deck
together there's a lot of things
that kind of came out of this
and the to and read that I I
want to point out to you and
that is. The scope of
productivity is huge when I walk
into a manufacture there's all
kinds of ways that we can help
them grow.
And there's obviously going to
be some job I've displacement
but I think net net. Automation
a robotic technologies allow for
the expansion of human
consciousness and the expansion
of jobs and new opportunities in
this region.
We're here sharing with
students.
Software that's used on a two
story tall LaserJet machine
that's just fascinating to get
the children around to see this
type of technology.
So some potential solutions for
manufacturers I'll go to the two
that I like the most here. And
that's the of managing the.
Pipeline like the supply chain
analytically driven to help.
Place the future process
of a students into these
positions and then the redesign
and the recent thinking of the
HR function in a manufacturing
environment.
Apprenticeship programs we've
heard a lot about them today
this is one of my manufactures
that have opened up from
national manufacturing day. The
students love getting into these
aye manufactures seeing.
Smelling and and watching these
amazing products being built so.
Thank you guys very much.
Thank you and now up is doctor
Gina fostered director of corona
Norco unified CT program.
Welcome
.
And thank you.
How about now okay good? Good
afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity to present to this.
Hearing.
And for the support of.
Assert both assembly members
that are here.
I truly appreciate your
commitment to CT <c.green> stem
a on</c>
education and then especially
assembly member savant as out of
it to our veterans.
Often it's my pleasure to
represent.
Not only career technical
education in this just in
California but also.
Front Norco unified school
district in the key twelve
education system.
L. as.
We moved through an I listen to
our other speakers and.
Op
where they've come from and what
they've talked about I think
it's important to note that if
we continue to teach like we
used to.
We're going to Robert children
of tomorrow and if you look at
the the picture that I have a
better. You see the old.
Odd dialup cellphone or.
Old phone rotary phone compared
to the new cell phones
I think that really talked to
what we're talking a ballot new
education. OB new methods of
teaching
one of my other thoughts on this
year's I'm about to be the owner
of a nineteen twenty seven model
eight. And of course that is
going to be my project in
retirement stuff history to
rebuild this now I can rebuild
that but if you ask me to go
into a two thousand eighteen. Of
Ford F. one fifty forget it I'm
not even gonna look at that car
so that just tells you the kind
of skills in the technical
skills that we are now. Teaching
our students to do.
In corona Norco unified school
district there are out we have
fourteen of the fifteen industry
sectors courses. Are impelled
which we offer.
Thirty three pathways within
those fourteen industry sectors.
Course there in various stages
of development.
Some of our most developed areas
our manufacturing and
engineering. Which lead truly
have a seventh grade through
twelfth grade and then fourteen
into the community community
colleges those develop pathways.
We also have strong new pathways
in the medical science in
medical technology.
An information communications
and technology.
On this next page one of the
growing.
Areas is definitely the health
sciences medical technology.
We are Everly grown this program
in the last three to four years.
El the district we have twenty
five articulated courses
throughout our.
K. twelve system with Norco
college.
Melt center Tonio community
A we are expanding our dual
enrollment programs right know
we have courses that Eleanor
Roosevelt high school. We're
looking to grow those at
centennial and.
Norco next year in them to the
rest of our comprehensive high
schools later on. Additionally
we have forty one courses that
me a third gene requirements
we truly believe in post
secondary education. Not just a
for year college education
although we do prepare students
to be college and career ready.
One of the exciting things that
is coming up is a previous pre
apprenticeship pathways.
All I've talked to some more
group college representatives
Theon. What I find most exciting
is?
With fender music or fender
guitar company located right
here in corona.
As far as our medical technology
programs we have pathways in
biotechnology a on patient care.
Students take trips to places
such as Loma Linda cadaver lab.
In the school of anesthesiology
in Pasadena.
We have an instructor and
students that are located in the
reception that a fifth set up a
display for more eastern program
and Roosevelt. And she is
working on two new junior and
senior courses. In infectious
disease and pathology.
As we move into robotics
yeah under coating we also
include the supply chain
technology program.
We do have another school set up
in the. Room next door from
corona fundamental intermediate
school that has.
A three D. printer in some of
the project that they've
developed as well as some of
these robotics.
But they plan on.
Demonstrating after this is
over.
We have teachers that a ten
industry training in adobe Max
order death game developers.
Solidworks you know I U. S.
scared. An SDS to structural
steel engineering.
Another program that we're
highlighting in industry sector
that we really are. Are moving
forward with is the
transportation industry sector.
We all of us an automotive
technology program. It whenever
I schools in you can see from
the pictures.
There's a simulated electrical
system trainer taught in our
automotive technology program
and what's cool about this
erodes the Chiu the instructor
can set the system up where a
student can troubleshoot.
The electronic system this
display had every electronic to
system.
In a car.
And so the students can
troubleshoot out.
Interior that we've been
looking to implement for the
last year for years that we're
finally going to do next year.
Is an aviation pathway one
course will be aerospace
engineering and we will also
have ground school.
Of course in that we can get
students started. In that
direction some of our business
partners includes compilers from
United Airlines. The
organization organization of
black aerospace engineers March
air reserve base and cal
Baptists is heavily involved in
our pathway development with.
Just a K. twelve were up
annoying fourteen sixteen of
beltway.
Next slide more into the
manufacturing in engineering.
We strive to purchase industry
based equipment such as because
of a Lincoln welders and
stratosphere three D. printers.
But industry certification for
our students are available in
adobe auto CAD snap on in solid
works as well as many other
areas.
We do have some other industry
sectors that I wanted to
highlight such as or
agricultural sciences program.
Are.
Metal.
Are cabinetry and mil working
program that we have it too high
schools. And we also have
information communication
technology program throughout
the district.
We heard the.
.
Games and simulations beltway
networking
software and systems
development.
Our continued needs include the
employer involvement were we can
do job shadow student turn ships
and teacher externship.
Course funding is always a
concern and we appreciate
assembly member Burke saw
sponsoring a bill that would the
continued US support fix career
technical education incentive
grant.
We certainly would like to see
the federal government fully
authorized a Perkins.
A legislation in fully fund our
programs from that standpoint.
In conclusion.
I want to stress that my school
district kroner unified school
district.
Fully believes that all students
can be college and career ready.
And.
They can achieve those through
a.
Rigorous and relevant.
Slash career technical education
program.
Yeah on would that.
Thank you very much for this
opportunity to showcase corona
Norco unified school district.
We will now hear from Catalina
missed blur chief a program
administration and services
division California student aid
commission.
Okay.
So thank you assembly member
Burke and assembly member
Cervantes on behalf of our
executive director Libby that
Cortez up a lot. We thank you
for inviting us to present
information on what the
California student aid
commission does and its efforts
to also. Provide resources to
those students who are pursuing
at technical career technical
degrees and certificates.
As you may know the commission
provides over two billion
dollars in cal grants
students attending. Four year
institutions community colleges
public and private.
We're proud to say that we work
towards.
Providing information to all
California high schools and
working with also the high
schools to ensure that all
students all high school seniors
have an opportunity.
To work towards.
Receiving a higher education
our mission is to make education
beyond high school financially
accessible to all Californians
and we're proud that we're able
to do that. We have.
Two programs in particular that
our outreach programs that we
worked directly with the
communities one is our cash for
college program. We have
workshops throughout the state
this year we're proud to say
that we reached over a thousand
cast for college workshops
hearing in California. Working
with our high schools are
community colleges and our
partners in the community as
well to promote these workshops
so that. Families from low
income and disadvantaged
backgrounds have the opportunity
to learn about financially.
We also in our in past year the
two thousand sixteen seventeen
year we had the opportunity as
you know with your the fast said
that started on October the
first. To start sending out
communications to high school
seniors informing them that what
financial aid was available to
them so that they could have the
opportunity. To search and to
look to see that maybe a four
year institution wasn't for them
but a community college or
vocational technical program was
available for them.
We received feedback from
numerous students and families
that they took that letter to
their college counselors many of
them believe that they didn't
have the financial resources to
go. Many of them when you when
you ask them about college and
many of them will tell you that
college isn't for them. But when
they learn about their
vocational educational
opportunities then that's when
they believe that they can take
those steps and they have the
financial aid resources
available. To get them through
those programs.
Well the cal grant a program and
the cal grant be program focus
primarily on the traditional
program degree programs at the
four year institutions. The cal
grant see program.
Is aimed at shorter certificate
programs
it's the primary source of state
based aid for career and
technical degrees and
certificates.
In prior years several laws were
passed to focus on the cal grant
see program it's one of our
smaller programs it offers a.
Seven thousand seven hundred
sixty one awards.
We've worked with that
employment development
department to identify long term
unemployed. So that they have an
opportunity to identify. The
types of programs that may be
made available to them and
financial aid resources
available to them. We also work
to identify high need high wage
and high growth occupations.
Currently the cal grant see
program is under utilized
and we are continuing to work
with our partners we've worked
with the California community.
That many because chances office
to identify students and where
they are and what types of
programs are enrolled in so that
we can so the students can take.
Advantage of these programs
we're also working with the edge
coalition to identify what ways
we can communicate and where we
need to reach out to the
students and families understand
what is available for them. To
continue their their education.
The cal grant see award the
amount in prior years we we're
proud to say that we're very
grateful and thankful to the led
the California legislature and
the governor. For increasing
year award amount on the cal
grant see program.
To two thousand four hundred
sixty two. Towards their tuition
and fees and an additional five
hundred and forty seven dollars
that you is used towards books
and supplies. At community
college students who are
enrolled in and career technical
education programs receive a
thousand ninety four to use
towards their their books and
supplies.
We have the opportunity to.
Follow up with the students and
we've learned. That through the
process in identifying the
students many of these cal grant
see students.
Do not qualify for the
entitlement program.
And there are students that
graduate directly from high
school who become eligible for
the high school entitlement
program but as you may know many
of the students who. Do not
enter college immediately after
high school and two years later
decide to take the courses
necessary. To increase their
training or their skill set.
They do not qualify for the cal
grant program and unfortunately
they lose an opportunity to have
an entitlement award. Therefore
the cal grant see program is
very important and it is one of
the programs that they get they
may qualify for and continue to
receive to. Help to offset the
costs of those.
Expenses for the uniforms for
books for any of the supplies
that they need.
Whether enrolled in their
vocational your career technical
education program.
We look forward to continue
working with the legislature to
see how we can improve the
program how we can reach out how
we can make the program more
available we're very happy to
see that the increase of the
award and we're very thankful to
see that the award was. Increase
as we do believe that there are
cost beyond what the students
can afford to attend in some of
these programs even with the
with some of the bog fee
waivers.
Some of that the institutional
aid that's provided to them
there's still a huge gap for
many of the students so work and
continue to work and hope that.
We can see an increase in these
programs in terms of the amount
and it continues to get it
apart that its need thank you.
Thank you.
Now for our final panelist
touchy on a tour is workforce in
training coordinator with great
alternatives.
Good evening and thank you for
giving her the opportunity to
come up and.
.
that we have.
To address some of the work
force.
Dishes that we've been talking
about during this panel.
Just to give you a little bit of
background about look good
alternatives is and what we do
where nonprofit.
.
Bob Hertzberg nurses in the bay
area will we do have a regional
office here in riverside that
covers the Inland Empire and we
have another one. That covers
that greater Los Angeles area in
LA so what we do is we install
solar electricity systems to
families that qualify depending
on where they live and their
income level on this or not at
no cost for this families.
So we like to say our triple
bottom line is we help people we
help the planet and we also
help.
Employment by connecting good
people in our communities that
need.
Good meaningful employment.
One of our programs that we have
is called out woman in solar
which is an initiative that's
working to build aye they burst
equitable and inclusive solar
industry by providing pathways.
To technical careers I
specifically for women.
To enter the solar industry aye
good alternatives we train all
of our staff so that are job
trainees and volunteers feel
safe as woman. And comfortable
working in solar jobs so.
How we do think volunteers to
help us out during this
instances where nonprofit we do
recognize that some of these
volunteers are actually looking
for jobs in the solar industry?
And they're with us because
they like the skill so.
We encourage woman to come on
board as job trainees and then
we help connect them with a real
jobs.
We also offer re entry
opportunities because good is a
supporter of second chances are
office in JLA have collaborated
with five key charter schools.
As well as homeboy industries to
provide training for the re
entry population. Our office
here in the Inland Empire last
year we partner with riverside
county juvenile hall swiped it
program we took two of their
interns.
They were both in their late
teens early twenties.
They computer that paid
internship with us while they
were still in the juvenile hall.
And one of them actually moved
on to our one year solar core
program so he's now employed
with us for one year full time
employment.
Our troops to solar initiative
provides solar industry
workforce training to US
military veterans and active
service members.
Across the country so this is
not just only happening. In the
Inland Empire or LA but this is.
And national initiative that we
have.
We have actually.
.
In our office here in riverside
we we have partner with the
mission continues which is
another nonprofit authors
veterans.
Right now we have to the mission
continues fellows in our office.
Three permanent staff that are
veterans.
And actually started as
volunteers and are working of
solar installers. And.
One better in turn as well.
And our solar futures program.
Aye were directed mostly with
us on a futures program a which.
The goal of this program is to
inspire the next generation of
solar leaders we serve youth
ages sixteen to twenty four.
Andrew partner with different
high schools passage of football
Valley high school.
.
And riverside unified school
district to provide both in
classroom training. And real
work training to.
High school youth so that they
can see what's out there in
terms of of jobs and we do
recognize that not all of them
are gonna go to college.
But those that do want to go to
college have something to put on
their resume and also have other
careers to think about. Within
that renewable industry and
those that don't want to go to
college get some hands on
training before they graduate.
When I going in there and I do
that in class and training for
the students we do have a
session where we teach about.
Alchemy reading as we teach them
about resume building. Job
interviews we teach them about
different jobs in the solar
industry both entry level or mid
skilled.
Jobs and also does where they
would require more education.
Tops in the solar industry are
continue to grow and the average
income for.
For a solar installers twenty
four dollars an hour and they
actually don't require.
College degrees.
And I a. National growing
impacts we've installed systems
for over a thousand four hundred
families nationally.
We continue to promote
workforce adversity in the solar
industry.
We've trained over two thousand
two hundred and twenty one
participants is to thousand
eleven here in the Inland
Empire.
How we advocate for state state
and federal policy we've trained
over four hundred and seventy
nine tribal volunteers are here
in the Inland Empire?
And the way we do our work is
throughs.
Local partnerships with CTE
programs Sau with different high
schools.
And with also political leaders
that recognize the importance of
the work that we do here at
Gran.
And this is actually our
national numbers with installed
over forty thousand kilowatts of
solar nationally.
Saved over three hundred
million dollars to families
sweeper.
Overall we've trained over
thirty five thousand people up
for jobs in the solar industry
and this our national numbers.
And the numbers again change
every single day because we have
installs every single day at our
office here in riverside we have
about. Two to three installs per
week and that every single
install we have volunteers
community members that are
looking.
To give back to their community
or also job trainees which or
people that are looking for jobs
in the industry.
And with artists I wanna thank
you for giving me the
opportunity to share about great
and though type of work that
we're doing.
Did Jeff.
To look like the other way.
A island had a question.
For Catalina.
What could we need you to help?
Facilitate more utilization of
that the cal grant see program
is it a function of not in
enough funds per.
Grander how is it what is the
actual issue.
The current process I have our.
Identifying who those students
are.
When we identifies students
eligible for cal grant and bees.
We identify those students as.
.
Students that have indicated
that they're pursuing a a degree
at a traditional degree. Those
students in the calcium program
bid what we do want is we want
to give those students who are.
Could qualify for an entitlement
ward that entitlement award
because it provides them more in
terms of the tuition and fees.
And it also provides in four
years of those benefits.
Those students who do not meet
those qualifications than. And
up in the pool of applicants for
the cal grant see program.
Once we identify who those
students are we send out a
what's called a supplement that
ask for additional information
to identify the types of
programs there and.
And I think sometimes students
are confused and the types of
programs are real Bigelow
enrolling classes they may not
know that the classes they're
taking organ and lead to a
particular. Certificate or
programs that she if the campus
that an identified as such. And
so they said will. Indicate that
they are identify themselves as
not being eligible for the for
the casi program.
If we had a better opportunity
to.
.
Get date out or identify those
students better who are in those
programs them we could directly
communicate with them and form
them and process them through.
And inform them that they're
eligible and just send the funds
directly to the campus identify
them on the campus rather than
having to go to this extra step.
Of completing this additional
form.
So my question is for Regina
first off I am very proud to
have corona Norco unified within
the district and thank you for
taking me along the tour. Not
too long ago.
I I actually won a highlight the
quote you mentioned that I like
you know how do you see
education.
Meet the jobs that.
Education has of course
changed tremendously over the
years.
Probably one of the biggest
impediments we have to continued
growth.
In our programs.
Course
financial we need to always work
on that but.
.
Burke. Teachers.
We desperately need industry
experienced teachers.
And without that of.
It's harder
to teach kids a one of my
favorite sayings from one of my
mentors was.
Bob people in my profession
career technical educators who
do come out of the industry.
The more where in education the
more we learn about education
and the less we work learn about
our profession.
So it's essential that we
continue to to. Have trained
professionals
in education. And also to
provide externships an
opportunities for current
teachers
to learn.
Thank you for sharing at my next
question I have for Dennis
actually thank you for. Aye
taking me out into different
parts of the district it was
actually just last week where I
went to a tour a woman ran
robotics company. So that was
pretty exciting aye but you know
wanted to kinda talk about your.
On your slide the potential
solutions for manufacturers.
You mention recruitment from new
sources such as veterans and
women you how do you effectively
recruit our community colleges
if you can just share. With us
I I I. I put them in touch with
I'm with Charles who was in the
room here I through an arch how.
Aye he's that princess ship
director that I've been working
with so I. Bring I make that
introduction to Charles and then
he vets the right apprenticeship
program to the and ploy yours
Nate.
I like the fact that said that
the previous question about
education I I'd love to see
educators out and the
manufacturers to see what's
changing. How the pace of change
is constantly evolving and to
stay current?
And I I I do towards I share my
manufactures with the community
with educators.
.
I liked intertwined them so.
Silver the representative from
grits alternatives I was
<c.green> I</c>
am a huge fan of your program
actually tried to come out
volunteer and I asked by to
climb on the roof they told me
no because I'm clumsy. But.
I'd I am curious at how where
do you where are you finding
your I mean I know I'm a
volunteer just because I work in
the I worked in the industry but
where you finding some of your.
Folks that are going through the
training program where they
coming from.
Yeah I currently am a lot of our
volunteers actually come through
partnerships.
And I spoke about that about
about Ursula futures program but
we also have.
Partnerships with community
colleges like college of the
desert.
They have.
Peavey program so they don't
offer the hands on training for
their students so they send them
to us to get that component we
also partner with.
.
Other.
Other schools as well and other.
I vocational schools the hive
Peavey training but they don't
have the opportunity to actually
show them what it really looks
like when they're out there in
the industry. So we partner with
them and they bring their
students to us.
I think we both have more
questions but we're were
overwhelmed by how many people
have public comment so what
we're going to is. To ensure
that everyone gets an
opportunity we're gonna move to
public comment portion of the
hearing.
Up for those that have indicated
that they would like to speak on
how we're going to ask you to
keep your comments down to one
minute at this point. To
accommodate as many people as we
can and I want to thank you all
for coming.
What?
That line up at.
The Dyess here.
Rendon one line we do into a one
liner.
You're going to do like.
One line here the diets for
those who signed up for public
comment.
Come on guys rear.
WTI.
It's help these folks out get
lined up.
Again we wanna thank you all for
coming today it's it's.
You know deserve porn issue and
and and and and important issue
that's going to we're going to
funding this year so we
appreciate your time.
The timer timer will be over
here.
To my right.
Begin.
Good afternoon.
My name's the safe I'm a small
business owner in corona.
Also on the board of directors
of crown a chamber so I
represent grounds chamber.
.
I was the chairman and twenty
fifteen and also currently chair
of. The legislative action
committee.
On behalf of our.
Twenty three chairman.
John why gap and the entire
board of directors and.
The crowd a chamber CEO Bobby
Spiegel who couldn't be here
today.
I'd like to thank of you.
Assembly member of Cervantes
and. Local college.
For your visionary leadership
and.
Bringing the business community
manufacturing council.
Our elected representatives
local governments and other
stakeholders.
Together to prepare us for the
growth needs of.
Are.
Region's future.
This an exciting.
Period of our development and
economic growth in our region
just last year.
Ground the chamber with the
involvement that partnership of
the city of corona.
Norco college NAVSEA just next.
Dress up here.
And members of the health
manufacturing.
Building industry and others
develop the chronic twenty
twenty platform.
Greta twenty twenty as a roadmap
to sustaining and growing our
current industries as well as to
work. With local college and
local governments to develop our
region. Into Hupp.
A destination.
At that attracts more jobs
businesses.
Industries not to mention result
the resulting reduction and.
Freeway congestion and miles
traveled.
And obstacle comment to any
economic development and growth
is the shortage of trained and
skilled professionals.
This problem has affected my
industry in automotives.
As well as.
.
Manufacturing industries such as
American national manufacturing.
That
Chad Miller with will address
health care. Science and
technology industry.
It is truly exciting to stand
here today and with this.
Next steps being taken to
address the career technical
education and the needs of our
industries in the growing.
Economy of our region thank you.
John Miller American action
manufacturing or manufacture
here grown. And we manufacturer
and many different devices
medical consumer aviation
aerospace we have seven
divisions.
And we struggle.
With skilled workforce that an
industrial sewers I worked with
Charles here at the college
trying to bring and others to
generation gap of industrial
sewers. And that's what we do we
so up mattresses
both on the medical side as well
as the consumer side.
A and we're trying anything we
can do to connect our industry
and industrial fabrics
with our education system and
with the businesses to get that.
That cohesiveness
to provide the the curriculum
and the facility to use our
experts.
there's a lot of burden on the
on the businesses
a step up and open their doors
and do exactly this I appreciate
all you gotta do.
We need more of that.
On our side I am part of the
legislative committee and a
board member for the chambers
while. I'm and so these
relationships are key and
critical for us.
On we do grow our jobs.
Nationally we have our are
expanding we're blessed to
really be expanding and and we
are having a hard time here so
anything you ask my son wasn't
crying high school and. What did
the?
Auto mechanics a class there is
now to in the military retired
from there now at. UT I learning
to be a mechanic so an example
of how we benefitted from that
so it's very important think
what you're doing and please
continue to more.
But I thought that's.
My name is Tom chan I'm a
scantron.
The assessment company for
someone to give out all shallow
to our classrooms she T.
teachers.
Because unlike many adult pilots
borrowing teachers so prep
teachers. Didn't get the kudos
de richly deserve as we all
know.
Because whether you are a
college bound or career path
bunk.
Good teachers make a difference
for a student success
so. Congratulations to our
teachers who are day in and day
out working with our students.
S. scantron we are looking for
public.
Private partnership to develop a
assessment.
In the area all C. T. E..
That's different than forty
years of academic assessment
we've been doing.
Because we want no ensured that
the few key students.
Have way too the licensure and
certification.
Them if they we want to develop
with our colleagues like we are
doing with Alabama state.
As well led Louisiana.
To develop a serious though.
Assessment that can address
their success so thank you.
Good afternoon.
I Melanie Murphy Corwin
and I'm a retired to.
Cater from
corona Norco unified.
And it's my honor currently to
be serving.
I as a commissioner for the
instructional quality
commission.
That works with the California
department education to a review
and.
And.
Revise all the frameworks and of
standards for all of Creek him
K. twelve in the state of
California.
Although computers have been
used in classrooms across the
state for many years we've not
had definitive standards based
on computer science core
concepts and compound COR
practices.
It is my great pleasure as a
commissioner.
To announce today that computer
science standards have been
developed by educators appointed
by the state board of education.
They have been written and they
will now go through the process
of review public comment editing
revision and revisions. Before
they are are ultimately OB taken
before the state board of
education.
I it is the goal of the I. QC
the California department of
education in St board education.
That implementation of the
standards.
Of throughout the state of
California will lead to the end
result that all students will be
prepared to enter college and
career. As both critical
consumers and also thoughtful
artistic creators and innovators
of computing technology.
And I thank you for all your
support.
They were names Charles and in
with that Norco college and they
got a like a partnership cell
and I one minute here I got.
Labor code seventeen seventy
seven point five I won't go do
it because we have such a short
time. But it does three things
for the construction industry.
Is one is a creates a
procurement.
Advantage and also performance
requirement ought to use the
premises and it saves
contractors literally thousands
of dollars.
When the user presses per
apprentice it's huge.
Are the other thing that it does
is it creates a sustainable
funding mechanism corps training
trust funds.
It doesn't exist outside
construction.
And it really doesn't exist
outside the state.
And that's why. California has
led an apprenticeship for eighty
years that's on that. Labor code
was enacted nineteen thirty
seven.
Most importantly though. Is what
it does is it provides a public
commitment to apprenticeship in
construction and at some we
don't have any other industry
yet. And so that's my
encouragement.
Is to look at look into that
look into those things at that
procurement advantage the
financial incentive.
And also the performance
requirements.
I am my name is Michelle denying
what the tech company called
elevate.
My background I for a number
years about fifteen years worked
on the streets in Boyle heights
with workforce development
grants.
Health and Human Services
education all those coming great
things and the way about their.
And I spoke with your chair of
the.
Riverside county web I'm gonna
be given a demonstration of our
software but essentially what
elevate is is I'm here to help
you guys. With everything you're
talking about today on a mad
genius your your social media
that we are on right but instead
of connecting with just adds in
trying to sell you junk in all
this fake news we get. Yours
your jobs scholarship
opportunities internships
community service projects are
fed to you based on your
location your interest the
school you go to.
.
And that helps build a resume
just likely intent because I
dimly den are young people
NASA's aren't Nestle Saralee
going to build a profile there
it's intimidating it's not
really their skill set.
But this will be that platform
to.
Compensate for that but it's
also gonna let all your
wraparound services not only
from your schools.
That how the work.
Force development.
Funding but every other funding
source all communicate together
and it's have become.
Good afternoon everyone.
My name is amber of Dahle I am
a junior at centennial high
school. And I am a state officer
for future business leaders of
America. So I end up here
because I really want to talk to
you guys about what high
schoolers see as the benefits of
CTE program.
And it's actually really
interesting that you guys are
hitting everything.
Spot on that we are requesting
that we want to see change in
schools.
Out we want career based
education's we want to learn
skills sets that we are
interested and we go through our
language arts classes in your
learning. How to analyze books
but these?
This isn't necessarily something
that most of us want to go into
literature. Aye we don't learn
resume building in our classes
but with the CTE courses like
business management leadership
and. Graphic design and culinary
arts we are learning skills that
we want to incorporate into our
creator soon I do you want to
see more at.
Made accessible in schools. Our
EP articulated CTE courses.
To provide more op trip
opportunities for all high
schoolers especially those who
are worried about colleges in
their GPA so I do you want to
see a lot more of those classes
because that's. The main reason
why a lot of us don't and we're
scared to take them
because we're scared of how they
might impact our.
High school career.
I'm incredibly honored to be
here thank you guys so much and
I'm really amazed at to see how
the back. Behind the scenes
works
of this all is and how much you
guys really. Taken are feedback
and. I appreciate everything you
guys do it's really fascinating
give.
I don't go anywhere yeah para.
I use one of these and they
never really quickly you are and
and and incredible example of
why we're working so hard on
career technical education your
eloquent. And intelligent and
you really we are proud to have
you as as. As an and as the.
A representative of what we're
trying to do here to thank you
for being here today.
Hi my name is Seth ground my I
am a junior at Norco high school
I am enrolled in.
The ag program there we
currently have roughly four
hundred twenty five members the
state of California there's
about eighty thousand. So what
this does for us it's it's it's
our RCT program that we have
Norco or one of them. What it is
it's?
Agricultural lated jobs what
it's teaching you teaching you
flora mechanics all those types
of jobs where you get your hands
dirty where you're out there
working.
So what is teaching us it's
teaching a step that we can use
out there in the field.
And so is teaching as not only
what we need to do to get a job
but it's also be paying us for
college. Because is teaching us
leadership skills
because it's not only the
classroom but there's a separate
part of it which is specifically
designed for leadership. Is
assigned a designed to teach us
how to work together as a team
and to we teams. We can take
that to our colleges and news
that there. To.
.
Give me so we can his that there
and. Help us get more access to
other things.
It also gives us a.
Connections to industry and
other people higher up so I
could from our program we have
gone to a.
We've gone to farms up in the
central Central Valley region so
we can learn all those types of
agriculture that we have there
and we've gone through. Some
mechanic mechanical things I've
gone to the Lincoln electric
center out there in Reno Nevada
so we can learn stuff about
that.
And so the future CD we're
really looking for more at.
More so funding because we are
currently it's a very.
.
Very expensive program like our
table that we just by far one of
our classrooms it was.
About four thousand dollars just
for one table so. It's quite
expensive so once again thank
you yes.
Well and I I actually want to
just say thank you the I'm
program at Norco high school is
quite impressive I went to tour
it I with my staff and so what
you are doing there is is an
example for. Many other schools
to also follow so if you to
please stay with us Oleanna I
would love to talk to you. After
this hearing Bankia.
Hello ó my name is leery of us
I'm a TV production teacher at
A. B. Miller high school I'm
here but minister.
Can Yellin and the I just wanna
talk a little bit about how.
CG has benefited I'm.
The program.
At that on our site and in in
Fontana. Off Montana just much
like the cities of the to you
serve our is working class
community and CT has allowed. Of
students are you know the
students in Fontana to be
exposed to industry than they
normally Paul wouldn't have been
exposed to and yes these
programs are expensive.
But.
These students are getting new
skills that.
You know many other schools
don't get the opportunity my
classroom.
Alone just last year received a
huge revamping renovation and.
We converted our our classroom
into a full on a editing studio
for all students as well as the
TV production studio where we
have our own studio in the
students run everything from the
lighting. To the audio to the
cameras there directing in
their.
And dubbed the great thing
about this is that we've been
able to establish.
Externships in internships with
QVC are in summer you know as
well as with Ontario I'm not
here today.
Hello. My name's Karen Bradford
I'm a trustee. With her repeat
unified school district and I'm
also on. The districts RCT
committee.
OB I recently visited riverside
can of city colleges gateway to
college program and saw how
nicely. Are Aug ZTE program
dovetails with yet.
Our I want to invite you to her
Ripper Valley high schools
innovation center it is
something that is so progressive
in its pathways to careers that.
I took along my oldest brother
he said when he was in college
he did not have programs. That
job would have served him as
well as our high school program
does.
As I've been listening to dare I
wanted to say that I'm concerned
about hearing the phrase living
wage linked with.
Of.
A technical education arm this
seems to imply a minimum and I
want everyone to know that it
can be an exceptional.
Road to liver of better than
living wages I have a master's
degree of taught it UC riverside
but both of my sons who have
what is considered. Considered
blue collar jobs make far more
money than I ever had so please
continue to support CT thank
you.
Hi I'm a teacher at all Kaiser
high school Bonta I've been as
to come on country but are grown
program.
We are we received a grant in
this office P. grant and we're
the plan year right now doing it
and the intent. Is to.
.
The kids ready for careers in
the droning street.
And.
A two year program the first
year of the in the first year
they're going to test for the
one all seven.
And the FAA one oh seven is
remote pilot certification.
And so the hope is that the day
test for that and six
the pastor.
Following year they'll go out
and do internships and we have a
grown to build on how drones are
being you
in industry. Out to a bill
designed modify these drones
that I'm I'm pretty excited but
the problem I think is a bright
future for the kids.
This kid is my grandson and I
brought him over to the program.
Because I think again
opportunity for all higher wage
jobs.
Quite frankly.
Retirement plan.
So I'm looking forward to that
and I I will say to know just
the technical side.
But many of us teachers
classroom teachers work very
hard and developing self skills
for.
The work.
No the others beside myself
always going oh over that with
the kids.
And I think of as they go to
this program internships it'll
that'll be reflect so thank you.
Thank you for supporting CT in
the funding my name is a Valley
McClellan I am a teacher in
Fontana at some high school. We
were able to start a new aye
pathway international business
so we have business and finance
where we have that and this
amazing taker Wall Street live
that goes around the classroom.
Kids are doing the Wall Street
game it's part of the curriculum
so when they come in and they
see that. It dropped.
It's a thank you for the support
that was through grant my are
entrepreneurship class which I
am I just took we had thirty did
her.
We've had aye.
Up to sixty kids compete skills
USA in the last few weeks were
waiting for results today. Sort
entrepreneurship we have a three
D. printer we also have print
screen that is what this kids
used for their products and then
they do their own business. And
as I said we've competed in
schools you're saying other
competition so. I'm and then our
capstone is the global logistics
where we've partnered with chief
ecology we've brought in. I'm
our industry partners to the
kids already gone out seem
logistics and seen industry and
the distribution center so. I'm
I'd like to say thank you
because I believe that CT
provides meaning a purpose for
our kids and that's what
motivates them to get that
certification on a two year for
you. So thank you for idea.
Good afternoon my name is
Kimberly Corbin I service the
principle of group of valley
high school. And we and we can't
tell you the difference that we
see in our students since we've
been able to really spend.
Really honestly money and and I
get the work force out there and
really make partnerships and
develop these.
State of the art centers for our
students
so we really ask as our grants
coming go that we consider the
flexibility of our LC up a
funding. Because what we built
we need it to be sustainable.
I'm we partnered for example
with great in this room and it
cost us to do this but we know
what our our students aye it's
benefiting the entire community
when we do this. So we invest in
them we invest in our community
so thank you very much for
considering that.
Good afternoon my name is a
funding host on the principle of
Fontana high schools we've heard
already from three of the high
school from the funding for
school district. My system
principle here miss by overseas
the CTE program which is what a
talk real briefly about programs
that we have and the impact it
has on our students. Their
students I can enter the promo
at sixteen years old when I won
that we do have is the fire
technology EMR program. We also
partner with chief because for
the EMT program CQC where they
wear uniforms a commensurate
days are there for eight hours a
day. May go to.
Job shadowing and the kids are
really enjoyed the see the real
world connection another we have
is our will be program there on
our campus where students
actually get certified. So
they're there until five six
o'clock at night the come in the
weekends ago to skills you say
the compete they take top honors
and the last words are full I
see in a program where. Our
students actually go and take
the state exams and they pass it
and they actually get to work at
the convalescent home they go to
a hospital so they do have that
real world experts and the
really really enjoyed. The walk
around campus with their scrubs
are now the kids playing you
what do you do in there to go
they get so excited effect one
of our students those in the
senior prom. Was going only do
CNA and then go straight to work
educators in the California
community college this.
Thank you so much for holding a
hearing for having us that
opportunity because you today we
especially want to thank you on
behalf of the association for
support of the strong work force
program funds.
Our programs are expensive and
working very hard to ensure
every dollar is focus on our
students in the classroom in
seamless partnership with our
key through twelve partners.
Through the California community
college a C. C. P. T. grant as
well as a strong workforce
program.
We're grateful for your interest
and aligning both the community
college courage cushion programs
in key through twelve courage
creation programs in the budget.
I'll mention that it from fiscal
year two thousand seven test
twenty seventeen that ten year
span.
The basic urge me the Perkins
basic state grant funding has
declined from the fed by
thirteen percent.
The house and Senate must now do
their job to begin the protest
of setting funding levels for
individual programs like
Perkins.
And see see CA we speaking the
finance department about this
but wanted to thank you for your
attention and noting that the
wind that pocket of money
evaporates.
It makes our job even harder in
which is why the vital support
we get from your bills and from
Chung workforce on and from
other state appropriations is so
vital for ensuring all these
expensive programs.
Critics from workforce exist.
I also in person at one I think
you assembly member savant as a
for your sponsorship of AB
fourteen a shooting nineteen oh
for. A to authorize a tax credit
us so that employees can
employers can hire registered
apprentices as we like to see
your local college the
registered apprenticeship
programs is college without the
debt.
Thank you very much.
I like to think and by the end
of today will know how to use
this microphone but I'd like to
thank everyone. Again today for
coming out and again I think.
As assembly member survived has
repeated eight think this was
one of the best.
Sheets we've found is if. We
teach today as we taught
yesterday we Robert children of
tomorrow I think that's what all
of our out of us in this room
school is is that we change the
education system.
That to better serve our kids
for their future. A I want to
thank.
Aside I wanna think Norco
community college in Dr Henrik
for having us here today. And of
course I want to think assembly
member savant is not only for
having us today but for her
continued commitment to career
technical education and to her
districts so. With that I turned
it over to someone members from.
Thank you I echo the sentiments
stated by my colleague assembly
member Burke I just hearing the
testimony today and the public
comment thank you for staying
till the end. Aye we certainly
appreciate getting your employer
whether you're from her for
unified school district credit
Norco you were in Fontana
unified. A we all need to work
together aye to achieve success
were students
I and our work force
I but it's been a great to hear.
Of from many of the panelists
today and how we can further
work together to really.
.
Yonge some of these challenging.
A issues that we face and of
course funding is always at the
core of it and where were in
Sacramento fighting for that day
in and day out. Aye but it's
it's good to work together in
your expertise and your what you
brought to this conversation is
vital a as we adjourn this
meeting know that we are here to
support your endeavors. A please
feel free to reach out to our
offices anytime I my district
staff is here to help you are
aware often in Sacramento
fighting.
On behalf of you on behalf of
our districts and students
across the state I so know that
your employer is vital to a lot
of the decisions that we make.
As so again please I welcome you
to join us at our networking
reception right after this I
will be right.
To the hall. Are believed to
the right.
So please join us and thank you
so much for participating today